[Music]
Hello brothers and sisters and members
of the SUM TV family. Thank you for
watching our I'd like to know our Bible
question and answer program. Thank you
so much for spending a little of your
time with us. My name is CA Murray. To
my left Pastor David Salazar, to my
right Pastor Stephen Bohr. And we're
here to answer your questions and we
have a good time doing so. Should you
want to be part of this experience, we
encourage you to send your questions to
tv@sum sum as in Mary tv.org.
That's tv@sumtv.org
and we promise we will get to your
questions just as soon as we possibly
can. And we want to encourage you, if
you have the opportunity please tell us
where you're writing from. It gives us a
little idea of our reach and how we're
helping the family of God worldwide.
Pastor David, if you would ask God's
blessing on us,
we'll start out with our questions for
today. Absolutely. Let us pray.
Heavenly Father, we thank you Lord for
giving us an opportunity to come
together to study your word, to share
and to be able to present an answer that
we pray it will give a clear
understanding to those who are watching
what is your will and what your word
says. We pray that you will also bless
us so that we may speak according to
your word and may we be led by the Holy
Spirit and those who are watching may
again may see Christ through us. We pray
this in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Pastor Bohr, would you read this
question? It is somewhat lengthy.
The person has asked us not to give any
information and we can understand why,
but would you walk us through the
question, please?
Uh yes, here's the question. It's
relatively long, but
it's not unique. Mhm. My husband's
daughter
in other words, her stepdaughter
is expected to get engaged.
My husband and his side of the family
are not Seventh-day Adventist.
And we anticipate that the wedding
ceremony may be scheduled during the
Sabbath hours.
Recently, my husband asked me whether I
plan to attend the wedding.
I gently reminded him that I observe the
Sabbath from Friday sunset to Saturday
sunset.
A sacred time for worship, rest and
deepening my connection with God.
As part of that observance, I typically
refrain from participating in social or
secular events.
Even those I care deeply about.
Well, he responded with understanding
and support.
I could see
the hurt in his eyes.
He asked if I could make an exception
just this once
for his family
and especially for his only daughter.
Pastor, I truly want to stand firm and
honor the Sabbath.
But I'm struggling with guilt and
sadness.
Why does doing what is right feel so
emotionally difficult in this case?
How can I let my husband go alone to
such an important event in his life?
I would greatly appreciate any spiritual
guidance, encouragement or counsel you
can offer to help me stay strong in my
faith while navigating this family
situation.
So that's the question.
It's a very you know, Pastor, it's a
very
similar or or
common situation that people go through.
When you are faced with this situation
where you are kind of torn between
following
a commandment of God, what God has
asked his follower to believe or to do,
or to
perhaps go with what
might
be more inclined to you, what you feel,
what your emotion tells you. You want to
be with your family, you want to be with
the, you know, your stepdaughter, you
want to be in that wedding and you're
anticipating that perhaps that wedding
is going to be happening on a Saturday
cuz usually that's how or the day that a
lot of people chooses to be married.
Um so first of all, I will kind of like
to tell our our dear sister here that
we have to remember the first um
uh this verse that is found in Proverbs
3:5 and 6.
Proverbs 3:5 and 6 and it says, "Trust
in the Lord with all your heart and lean
not on your own understanding. In all
your ways, acknowledge him and he shall
direct your path." The first thing is
that we have to know that
we need to put our trust and our desire
to follow what the Lord says before
anything else. And when you put your
trust with your whole heart in the Lord
then he will direct and
clearly make you understand what is the
right thing to do. In this particular
case, going to this particular answer I
think that is very clear in the Bible
that the Sabbath is the day of the Lord.
It's not the day of man, it's not the
day of us to do our own way.
And as much as I understand then that is
hard to be with a family, I think that
you know, you need to maybe ask the Lord
to give you the
the
grace before your daughter or your
stepdaughter and ask her to maybe move
do the wedding on a Sunday. Perhaps you
can avoid the whole
situation being torn on a day by asking
them to move to Sunday.
And if that's not the case, if they want
us to do it still on a Saturday and you
know that that is going to go against
you spending time with God
I I will say that God rather, you know,
you rather choose what God says rather
than what man may say.
I want to to approach it from another
angle. Mhm. I fully cosign what you
said. We have record of Ellen White
attending a wedding ceremony on Sabbath.
Um I was trying to get the text before I
ran in here, but I did not. Mhm. She
makes a statement that the wedding is a
sacred ceremony.
It It came to us from Eden pre-sin.
Um the problem is the folderol, all of
the push and pull, the servant valley of
the reception and all of that other
stuff. And what happens in preparation
before. And precisely.
>> styling, all of the dressing and talking
about worldly things and everything. So
before the before and after. Yeah. Yeah.
So and that's where it kind of gets, for
want of a better word, adulterated. Uh
but she he mentions
after church service, they pushed the
chairs aside and they had a very sacred
ceremony. They didn't have the
reception, they didn't do all of that
stuff. It was a plain wedding ceremony.
So that may give you some encouragement.
I would never attend
wedding receptions as I see them. I
could not in any conscience to do that.
But
I would pray about the wedding ceremony
itself because you're not part of all
that
as long as you keep yourself separate
from all of that stuff. Mhm. To to
have someone give their life to someone
else.
Yeah. I don't think that's an
anti-Sabbath Right. uh
occupation. It's something that But you
got to
And and this is this is
I mean, the line is tight here. You you
you've got to try as best you can to
separate yourself from all of that
ancillary stuff Mhm. that has nothing to
do with Sabbath, that has nothing to do
with the sacred ceremony. Um
There is a a record, I believe, of her
attending a funeral on Sabbath, also.
Um
So again, you've got to pray and get
freedom from from from your
for yourself. But the wedding ceremony
is a sacred ceremony. It's the other
stuff that's that is non-sacred and that
as a Christian, as a Seventh-day
Adventist, you cannot involve yourself.
You cannot involve yourself.
I just wonder whether
this applies
to this particular situation.
>> Mhm.
Because when Ellen White
was present at a wedding it was a
wedding of believers.
And it was after the worship service.
Which means that there were not a lot of
preparations before.
There was not a lot of big reception and
everything afterwards.
>> True.
This that she's talking about is a
wedding between unbelievers.
And you say, "Well, unbelievers, well,
maybe they're Christians." Ellen White
says that an unbeliever is one who does
not embrace our faith, our Seventh-day
Adventist faith. Right. And so
if it's a non-Adventist wedding, you can
be sure
that
they have to be involved in the
preparations
and they have to be involved in the what
happens after the wedding.
Um
Yeah, she herself recognizes. She says,
"Why does doing what is right
feel so emotionally difficult in this
case?"
She answered her own question.
>> Yeah. Doing what I would do. Because
because she says difficult in all cases.
that it feels right
but why does it feel so so wrong?
Um we have examples in the Bible.
For example, from the very beginning
Adam and Eve. Mhm.
You know, what was Adam's sin?
Adam's sin was that he loved Eve
more than he loved the Lord. Mhm.
At that point in time
>> So, the question is, does she love her
daughter more than she loves the Lord? I
know that that's putting it bluntly,
but it's the truth.
>> Mhm.
You have Daniel.
The king generously
provides his wine and provides his foods
for Daniel.
>> Mhm.
And as far as Daniel is concerned,
you know,
he could have emotionally felt, "Well,
the king is really generous, you know,
uh he's giving us all of this good food
and all this good drink. Let's not
offend him."
>> Yes.
But the Bible says that Daniel purposed
in his heart that he would do what was
right.
And when we do what is right,
it is always the best thing.
Um we ought to obey God
rather than man. A very well-known text
that we find in the book of Acts.
Uh so, the point is,
don't feel bad
that you're following God's principles.
>> Mhm.
Just ask your daughter,
uh your daughter-in-law,
uh would it be possible to schedule this
on a Sunday
so that I can be there for your wedding
and uh at the same time, I can live in
harmony with with the principles that I
believe in.
So, now, if there's going to be a a
religious wedding without any
preparations, without any reception
afterwards, you know, with uh out a
whole bunch of uh unbelievers that are
talking about secular worldly things,
that's one thing.
Another thing is a secular wedding on
Sabbath. Uh that uh that can run into
problems. That's my own personal
perspective. Mhm. But,
marriage is a sacred institution. Mhm.
>> When it is entered to as God has told us
to enter it to.
I don't believe that you know, that Adam
and Eve there was a lot of uh
hairstyling and you know, talking about
secular things and putting on the makeup
and all these things and then afterwards
they have to be this big refre-
reception with serving of food and
everything.
I don't see that happening in the Garden
of Eden. It was a simple wedding Mhm.
where God uh said,
"What God joined together, let not man
cast asunder." Mhm. Amen.
You know, there is a passage in
scripture that often times we, you know,
listen to it, but we don't really
put ourselves in the situation. And I'm
going to read that in Luke chapter 9,
verse 59 through 62. There Christ speaks
to two individuals. And I think it's
important for us to remember what it
says. Again, this is Luke 9, 59 through
62. It says, "Then he said to another,"
Christ said, "Follow me."
But he said, "Lord, let me first go and
bury my father."
Jesus said to him, "Let the dead bury
their dead,
but you go and preach the kingdom of
God." And another also said, "Lord, I
will follow you, but let me first go and
bid them farewell who are at my house."
But Jesus said to him, "No one look
having put his hand to the plow and
looking back is fit for the kingdom of
God."
The Lord's speaking here and he's
basically letting us know that we can't
go by emotion. We can't make decisions
based on our feelings, based on what,
you know,
might might might happen to our
to our family members. If we are not
participating The first one is asking
for a funeral. I want to go bury my
father. Jesus says, "That's not right."
And the other one, you know, I have to
go bid farewell to those in my family.
The Lord says,
"You have to make a point to put me
first. Choose me first before anything
else." And this is where again
the Bible verse mentions in 2
Corinthians 5:7, "For we walk by faith,
not by sight." Not by what I feel, not
by what I see, but what the Lord tells
me to do. And as you said, Pastor, and I
think I mentioned at the beginning, you
know, maybe she needs to put put in the
Lord's hand, pray and say, "Look, give
me grant me
grace before my daughter my you know,
stepdaughter and maybe I can convince
her of the benefit of doing on a Sunday.
Lord, work it out. Maybe the venue is
going to be more expensive on a
Saturday. Everybody wants to use a
Saturday for weddings. God we can open
the door for Sunday to be open." I mean,
ask the Lord, but make the covenant and
the decision to be faithful to the Lord
as as you said with like Daniel did. And
um if it does the situation and that's
the case, God can open the doors for you
for you to ascend. And if he's not
opening the doors for that, then stay
with the Lord first. Put him first and
you'll see that the rest comes as a as
as as as a blessing in the sense that
you can be an influence of good to them
still even though you're not there. And
I think it's important that uh
this lady who who wrote to us Mhm. uh is
nice nice about it. Of course. Because,
you know, we can come across as being
legalistic. You know, I serve God, you
know, I can't come to your wedding on
Sabbath.
>> that's not the case. No, uh
you need to explain what your
convictions are, that you go by what the
Bible says. We don't know if the
daughter-in-law is really uh religious
or not, but just express what your
convictions are, give uh your reasons,
and uh leave the consequences with God.
The big question is, what is worse? Mhm.
Offending a daughter or offending the
Lord? Mhm. I think that's the question
that needs to be answered.
>> Important point. Mhm. Important point.
Important point. Her heart seems to be
in the right place.
>> Right. Amen. And if your heart is in the
right place, then God will will work his
help and help you work it out.
>> Absolutely. Um
the thing is doing right
when you're in a world that
is moving towards wrong always going
make you kind of lonely.
>> Listen, John.
>> Yeah. You know, Yeah. uh but you're
never really alone because God will
stand by your side. Amen.
>> We hope that um our discussion has been
of help for you,
uh help to you, and um
we'll be praying. We don't have a name,
but certainly the Lord knows the name,
he knows the case. And um we put it in
God's hands. Thank you so much for for
the question. Maybe we can pray right
now.
Pastor Salas, how would you like to play
pray for this person?
>> Absolutely. Let us pray. Heavenly
Father, we thank you for allowing us to
come before you and for your grace and
your love towards us. Uh we know that
our dear sister who is uh
trying to do the right thing, doing
what's right for your eyes and also to
be able to be a help and to serve her
daughter-in-law or stepdaughter.
I know that it's important for them to
know um you and for for the family to
know that she is doing what's best in
her power to do. So, please I ask that
you will give her uh grace and may you
work in this situation in a way where
she can be faithful to you and at the
same time present the love, the care,
and the attitude of service to her
stepdaughter that it may bring uh unity
to that family and may she be able to
connect with them and present them the
beautiful um love of your character
through her actions, through her words.
Bless her and give her guidance and
allow her to On your name we pray this
in Jesus' name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. You know, it looking at the her
her question, a lot of this is
speculation. She says it may happen, it
may be scheduled on Sabbath. So, maybe
you can get in and add a little counsel
to me. I'm so been a Sabbath and been so
long, I don't even think of weddings on
Saturdays. Just always been Sunday for
me for 50 years. And I've done a fair
amount of weddings.
Uh so, good question.
Uh God bless. And maybe, you know, we
answer the questions in order and we do
the program before
uh this is probably going to air down
the road. Mhm.
>> Might be a good idea for us to contact
the people who do the scheduling and
schedule this one before uh the decision
has to be made.
Yeah. Let's get this one Yes, on air uh
as soon as as as possible. We we pray
the Lord for that. All righty. Um
I think we have time to get in this
question. Um 6 minutes and change. Um we
don't have a name as to where this is
coming from. It The question is on the
year of tithing. Year of tithing.
Third year of tithing. I want to
understand what that is. Reading the
Bible, I found some references to
year of tithing. This is in Deuteronomy
26:12. Pastor David, if you'd go to that
very quickly. Can you explain or
S- Can you explain at or to what is
referring this is referring and what I'm
supposed to do in order to do exactly as
God requires from me and as exactly my
duty is to the Lord. I want to give him
all my money if necessary, but I know
that he only wants me to worship him
according to his commandments, decrees,
and statutes, not according to any
possible fanatical or foolish
sentimental worship feelings. Thank you.
So, he wants an explanation
of Deuteronomy 26:12 and how that would
apply to us uh Christians today. All
right, let me read that verse. It says,
"Deuteronomy 26:12,
when you have finished laying aside all
the tithe of your increase in the third
year, the year of tithing, and have
given it to the Levite, the stranger,
the fatherless, and the widow, so that
they may eat within your gates and be
filled."
Sort of that's what the verse says
there. Mhm.
All righty, what is being dealt with
here? One of the things that jumps out
at me right away is this is part of
God's social security plan.
Mhm. To take care of poor, to take care
of the Levites who had no inheritance of
their own, so they live lived at the
behest of the generosity of the people.
So, this was
uh
God's way of dealing with those who had
not and those who by statute could not
farm and do all the kinds of things. Uh
this was God's plan to take care of
them.
Correct. This is interesting to to help
you understand there is three types of
tithing that were asked of the
Israelites.
This is actually the first one is the
first tithe, which was the yearly
support that was to be given to the
Levites.
Uh that is found in Numbers 18. The
second tithe, this is the festival
tithe, and we actually were talking a
little bit about it in the previous
program that we recorded, but it says
that it is the festival tithing that was
that you can find in Deuteronomy 14.
Uh and that was given as a tithe to
celebrate and rejoice for the Lord, the
second tithing. And the third tithing or
the third year of tithing, this is the
third year that
uh every third and sixth year of the
7-year cycle of agriculture,
the third year was
a tithe that was given for the poor, for
the fatherless, and it was a way, as you
well mentioned, Pastor, of giving social
uh a social security system in a sense
for for the people in Israel. It was
separated for God, uh for the people who
are needing support, poor, widows,
fatherless, and that was the way that
they will have, you know, something to
eat and to be able to to live off. So,
first tithe, the the yearly tithe for
the Levites, second tithing was one for
the festival that was done. And the
third uh tithing, which is every 3 years
of the 7-year cycle, so the third and
the sixth year was given for that
specific reason. And Ellen White
uh wrote about this, Mhm. and she said
that this applied to the sabbatical year
and the Jubilee. Mhm. Uh want to read
that statement, Patriarchs and Prophets
534 and 35.
The provisions of the sabbatical year
and the Jubilee would
in a great measure set right that which
during the interval had gone wrong in
the social and political economy of the
nation. This is exactly what you were
saying, CA.
These regulations were designed to bless
the rich no less than the poor. Mhm.
They would restrain avarice Mhm. and a
disposition for self-exaltation,
and would cultivate a noble spirit of
benevolence.
And by fostering goodwill and confidence
between all classes,
they would promote social order, the
stability of government.
>> Yes. We are all woven together in the
great web of humanity, and whatever we
can do to benefit and uplift others will
reflect in blessing upon ourselves.
The law of mutual dependence runs
through all classes of society. The poor
are not more dependent upon the rich
than are the rich upon the poor.
While one class ask a share in the
blessings which God has bestowed upon
their weightier neighbors,
the other need the faithful service, the
strength of brain and bone and muscle
that are the capital of the poor.
So, powerful statement about what this
text is really telling us. It's a social
security system where the rich are to
care for the poor,
and the poor are to benefit from the
blessings that God has poured out upon
the rich.
>> Amen. And it's not always just one-way
thing. I'm giving, I'm giving, I'm
giving, I'm giving. God sees to it that
when you give and you give heartily and
you give with joy, you receive. There is
a blessing that a reciprocal blessing
that comes back just in the act of
giving.
It is more blessed to give than receive.
And when you open your hand, you you may
lose some, but you also get some back
also. When you close your hand, you
don't get anything. You keep what you
have, but you don't get anything new.
So,
your point is well taken. Jesus was
right when he said, "Give and it will be
given unto you."
>> Amen. Amen. Amen and amen.
Again, just a couple of questions we've
got through, but
we don't really apologize for that
because you take the time to write, we
need to take the time to answer
thoroughly. Hopefully, this program has
given you information and inspiration,
and we'll see you again soon here on I'd
Like to Know. God bless. See you again
soon.
[Music]